what we're going to do now is we're
going to talk about student loans
there's a massive problem with student
loans in this country so if you think
about the student loan problem here in
america we've got a ton of different
numbers but first we're going to show
you this big chart of just how bad it is
there's a historic total national
student loan debt balance this is
measured in trillions of dollars
remember the number you're about to see
is measured in trillions not billions
not millions not thousands it's measured
in trillions of dollars and what we have
seen is since 2003 it has just been up
and to the right can't stop won't stop
that's all this chart does is it goes
higher and higher and higher if there
was a way to bet on a financial asset
and that financial asset was is the
student loan debt in america going to go
up or down you could go yolo long
levered and you'd still make money
because it only goes up we now are over
1.7 trillion dollars in the entire
national student loan debt balance now
when we actually break it down by the
numbers what we see is that there's 43.2
million student borrowers that are in
debt and they have an average of 39 000
of student loan debt each
each of the 43 million students have
39 000 of student debt on average the
average public university student
borrows thirty thousand dollars to
attain a bachelor's degree
in may of 2020 nine percent of borrowers
who attended public institutions were
behind on their student loan payments so
not only do we get a situation where
there's tens of millions of people who
have student loans but they have very
big balances over thirty thousand
dollars is the average balance meaning
fifty percent of it is higher than that
on top of that these student loans many
times have pretty egregious interest
rates that you have to pay given what
they are especially that we're giving
them to young people and then you add in
that in may of 2020 nine percent of
people were behind i'm sure that that
number has actually increased over time
given the financial hardship that many
people have experienced and so when we
look at this problem you can see that
it's really really bad now the private
student loan debt is not necessarily
much better the private loan borrowing
cons constitutes eight percent of the
outstanding student loan debt and the
national private student loan balance is
137
billion dollars so there's a market for
the public student loans right then
there's the private market where people
actually go and borrow student loans as
well so 137 billion dollars on top of
what is being done publicly now the
sources of this we've got a chart that
shows the educational debt among
borrowers student loans 95
credit 23
other 11 home equity loans are only 4
now when you look at this chart and you
see the sources of educational debt
among borrowers it is so damn high now
when we actually start to break this
down 5.8 percent is the average student
loan interest rate among all student
loans both federal and private the
average federal loan interest rate is
4.1
so when you start to actually look at
this four to five percent interest rates
on 30 plus thousand dollar balances for
tens of millions of americans it is
really really really bad now this is the
average interest rates for all federal
loans you can see that it was all the
way up at seven percent it came down to
six it kind of oscillated between five
to six percent and then recently in 2020
and into 2021 it dropped all the way
down to 4.2 percent or so the 4.2
percent is really important because what
the 4.2 percent says is that compared to
seven you pay drastically less but that
doesn't necessarily mean that the
problem is solved when you have this big
of a student loan problem billions and
billions and billions in the private
market 137 billion or so but then also
the federal student loans is over 1.7
trillion dollars
tens of millions of people holding it
and paying four to five percent today
they have been paying six or seven
percent over the last few years there
are people who graduated college 10
years ago 15 years ago and they still
haven't paid off their student loans
that's a problem when we have young 18
to 22 year olds who are going into the
workforce and they are already starting
behind the starting line they're not
starting out just like everyone else
they're starting out actually in the
negative they have debt and they've got
to work their asses off to get out of
debt one of the things that you can do
is you can actually go and you can get a
refinancing of your student loan so this
is one of the biggest tips that we're
ever going to tell you on this show now
i am not an expert in refinancing
student loans but right now after i
spent a couple of hours talking to the
team over at sofi they walked me through
exactly how this works so if you have
let's say a federal student loan that
federal student loan that you may be
paying four or five percent on and that
is on average tens of thousands of
dollars for tens of millions of people
what you can do is you can go and so far
has done this now for over 375 000
people which is pretty nuts number and
you can actually go and get a lower rate
by refinancing it's just the same way
that you would have a mortgage and then
if the interest rates drop you can
actually refinance your mortgage you can
do the exact same thing with your
student loans and so when you think
about this idea of these private student
loans as an option to refinance it
becomes a really powerful tool
in your financial journey